it's a Panama in the summer it's a
fedora in the winter so I change my hats
with the season also my drinks but it's
fun I'm now identified by my hat which
means less people are wearing them and
have been really since John Kennedy
didn't wear one it is inauguration in 61
it's vodka or tequila in the summer
white white drink white liquor and a
scotch good scotch in the ID I'm sorry
in the summer and good scotch in the
winner both of which tastes good I mean
I am I went to law school I tell people
I passed the bar it's the only bar I've
ever passed
well if I can fight one person I could
take i'd take somebody I could beat if I
would take one person I just want to
watch them hit the hell out of me it
depends if i wanted to ratatat me like
Willie pep would probably be behind me
before I'd look around or if I wanted to
see a star in the ring and stars in the
sky because I hit me so hard a Joe Lewis
I used to spar with Ali all I proved was
my nickname as a kid when I boxed in
college I was called a great white
hopeless I was terrible but I loved it
if I don't make the last payment on
these teeth the dentist is going to repo
him you know what I just love I love
sports and I love boxing and baseball
because his individual effort I know
they're eight other men in baseball but
it comes down to one man the pitcher and
one man the batter and they're competing
same in boxing mano a mano that way I
love both sports probably for the same
reason and I know a lot of fans baseball
players who are boxing fans and vice
versa because there is that similarity
to the two that it's a one-person
achievement